All right here. He [inaudible].
Okay. I guess what life, uh,
as as Arthur was saying, please
enter your son. It's ID. Uh,
we can bring this up again
at the end of class today.
We're just take another like what,
20 seconds and then we'll,
we'll go into the main discussion.
All
right.
So, um, what I want to
discuss with you today is,
um, uh, may, why were they called full
cycle deep learning applications, right?
Um,
and so, um, I think this Sunday, uh,
you'll be submitting your proposals for
the class projects you do this quarter.
And, um, in most of the, uh, in,
in a lot of the West you learn
about the machine learning projects.
You learn how to build
machine learning models. Um,
one of the one to do today is share with
you the bigger context of how a machine
learning model, how a
neural network by train, uh,
fits in the context of a bigger project.
Uh, so what are all the steps, right?
Just as if you're writing
a software product. Yeah.
You take other classes and learn you,
oh,
what happened there that teach you
how to build a website, for example?
What does that,
um,
but to build a product requires more
than just building a website. Right?
So what are the,
what are the other things you need to
do to actually do a successful software
project? And in this case
to do a successful machine
learning application? Um,
and so, uh, let's see.
So to Oh, Yep. Oh, test,
test is the audio on test.
Could you turn off the audio?
How's this? Yup. Can't hear me. Hello.
Hi. Oh, I think I'm broadcasting.
I hear myself great.
Okay. You can hear me now.
Great. Thank you. Alright,
thank you. Alright, so one,
the one that did his share of you,
um, full cycle machine learning,
not just how to, uh, you learn a lot
about how the built deep learning models,
but how does that fit in a bigger project,
right?
Just as if you're taking the clause
on building a website, then great.
You didn't know how the code,
they have a website that really valuable,
but whether all the things you need to
do to make us successful website to build
their,
build a project that involves launching
a website or a mobile app or whatever.
Um,
so as,
as you plan for your class
project proposals due to Sunday,
uh, if you're doing an application project
that fits in the context of a bigger
application also keeps on with
these steps in mind. Right? So, um,
you know,
these are what I think of as the steps
of an ml project or really
maybe maybe not fast project,
but maybe are serious machine
learning application. Right?
And I think,
I'll know I've built a lot of machine
learning products over several years.
So some of these are also things that
I wish I had known like, you know,
many years ago. Um, one,
this was kind of maybe kind of obvious,
but you know,
a problem.
And let's say for the
sake of simplicity data,
you use supervised learning,
right? It turns out for the
CSU 30 costs, Rajai eggs,
I think more than 50% of the class
projects tend to use supervisor.
And then there are also
other projects they use.
And I've using gans we should talk about
later this quarter or other things.
But I think,
you know,
let's say you supervise there anything
to take build that you're seeing
application. Um, and,
and I think for today I'm going
to use as a running example,
building a, um, uh, building a
voice activated device. Right? So,
you know,
uh,
I don't know actually how many of you
have like a smart speaker in your home,
like a voice activated device in
your home, you know, in the US? Well,
not that many of you are
interesting. Okay, cool. Yeah,
so I think, uh, uh, you know,
the Amazon Echos Google homes, that apple
series or the, the in, in, in China,
my one of my former team
was built by two zero s uh,
but let's say for the sake of argument
that you want to build a voice activated
device and I'm going to use
it as a running example. Um,
and so in order to build a voice
activated device, and again,
I'm not going to use any of the commercial
brands like Alexa or okay Google or
hey Siri or I guess in China was a hello
sal duty while the south do anyhow,
which means kind of roughly,
hello little do. Um,
but let's use a more neutral word,
which is he wanted to build a device that
your response there where it activates
and you're actually going to implement
it as a problem set later this quarter.
Um,
but so you want to build a yeah,
nope. Volume. Uh, uh,
let's see how that, okay. Is this
better now? Yes. No, this is better.
Okay, cool. Thank you. Logan.
Ironic talk about speech recognition
and the volume is higher. Okay.
Um, so let's say you
want, wow, let's do that.
Let me know if they've come software
gave it. Thank you. Um, so let's,
you want to build a voice activated
device. So the key components,
the key machine learning and deep learning
components is going to be a learning
algorithm that takes us input
and audio clip and outputs.
Um,
did it detect
what's sometimes called a trigger word.
Now did I go software game? Okay,
this is okay, great. All right. And,
and I'll plus y zero one digit to check
the trigger words such as Alexa or okay
Google or hey Siri or a
hello little do or, um, uh,
or activate or whatever wake where
they'll trigger word, right? Um,
and so
step one is a select a problem.
Um,
and then in order the trainer
there learning algorithm,
you need to get they both data.
If you apply supervised learning
and then you design a model,
use back prof or some of the other albums
you've learned about momentum, Adam,
you know, various optimization algorithms,
gradient descent to train the model.
And then maybe you
testing all your test that
and then you deploy it.
Meaning just start selling these
smart speakers and you know,
putting them into hopefully
until your uses homes. Um,
and then
you have to maintain the system. They'll
talk about this later as well. Uh, and,
and this is not chronological beds.
Uh,
one thing that is often done but I want
to talk about today at the end is dead.
It's not really, step eight is a
Qa, which is a quality assurance,
which is an ongoing process.
Right? And so, um, one,
uh, let's see. So as you said,
if you want to build a product,
everyone selling machine
there any product,
these are maybe some of the key
steps you need to work on. Um,
some observations when you train them
all though training them all the is often
a very iterative process. So every time
we train the machine learning model,
you find that, you know, I can
almost guarantee whatever you do,
it will not work, at least
not the first time. Right?
And so you find that even though I've
written it as a sequence of steps,
when you train them all though young ago,
know that neural network architecture,
it didn't work.
I need to increase the number of hidden
units or change the realization or such.
They're RNN or switch to a
totally different architecture.
And sometimes you train them all day
and go, nope, that didn't work. Um,
I need to get more data.
Right?
And so this is often a very iterative
process where you're cycling through, um,
oh to several different steps
here. Um, and then I think, uh,
one distinction that you have not yet
during the ball in the Coursera and the
deep learning.ai Coursera videos is how
to split up the data into train death
and tests. So I'm going to
simplify those details for now,
but just as a foreshadowing,
I guess
you learn later in the, in
the, uh, deeply into AI,
Coursera videos is how to take a data set.
You have training to excuse me,
the entire training set, um, uh,
into a set that you actually test,
cross validate using during development
called the deaf center development sets,
or hold our cross validation set
as soon as a separate test set.
So you learn about this later, but I'm
just simplifying a little bit for today.
Okay. So, um, uh,
so I think,
um,
the first thing I want to do
is ask you a question, right?
So we're going to talk through
many of these steps. Oh.
And it turns out that, um,
what a lot of machine learning classes
do and do a good job to change is
focusing on maybe these three steps.
So maybe these four steps,
right.
And one of the ones that do
today is spend more time.
So this is the hearts and machine
learning. How do you build a great model?
A and one other one that do today is
spend more time talking about step one and
six and seven and then just a little
bit of time talking about the call this
because you kind of need to do the
steps was well you want to go with deep
learning product. I'll go on the
machine learning application. Okay. Um,
so let's start the discussion question.
Um,
I'm actually curious,
uh,
if you are selecting a
project to work on, uh,
uh, what are the actually,
so I don't,
don't answer this yet.
I'll tell you what the question
was going to ask is, which is,
all right, uh, what properties make for
a good candidate deep learning project.
But don't answer yet right though.
I want to say a few more things before I
invite you to answer, which is that, um,
all of you for the last few days I hope
have been thinking about what pressure
you want to do for this cause.
And what I want to do is just discuss
some properties of what are good projects
to work on and what are maybe not
good practice and work on. Okay. And,
and think of this as your chance to
give your classmates advice, right.
One of the things you're
consummation should think about,
the shiny decides this is a good
price, the work on. Okay. Um,
and so what I want to do
for today is, uh, use, um,
this voice activated thing as,
as a, as a motivating example.
And you know, there's actually
one project I was working on.
Uh, the, there's actually a
thought that we're actually,
there was one project I
thought that working on with
decided not to work on, uh,
and that, that there's a voice activated
device. So it turns out that, um,
these voice activated devices
and Echo Google homes and so on,
they are taking off quite rapidly.
In the U s and around the world. Um,
it turns out that one of the,
you know,
significant pain points of these devices
is the need to configure it, right.
To set that up for Wifi. So I've done
a lot of work on speech recognition,
you know, a hotel dialogue
work and Google speech system.
I let the buy to speech system.
So I've been published papers and
speech recognition and I have a,
I have one of these devices in my
home, right? Uh, actually I was,
I have the Amazon Echo in my living room.
Um,
but even to this day I have configured
exactly one light bulb to be hooked up to
be controlled by my echo because the
setup process, not blaming any country,
it's just difficult to hook up,
you know,
it Wifi enabled light bulb and then to
set it up so that your smart speaker or
whatever, I was going to say, you know,
smart device turned off to the lab.
So I have one light bulb in my living
room where I can turn on and off and
that's it, right. Even as
a speech researcher. So
I'm going to say a bad
example. Um, so one, one,
one application that I think dead I was
actually seriously cause were working on
is to build a embedded device that
you can sell to lamp makers so that,
I don't know where you buy your downstroke
and you'll have a few labs or my
career or a few labs or wherever,
but you can buy a desk lamp so
that when you buy the desk lamp,
there's already a built in microphone
so that without needing to connect this
thing to Wifi, you know as a,
Hey, here's a $20 a desk lamp. Um,
but then on your desk and you
can go home and say desk lamp,
turn on or turn off a.
Then I think that will help a lot more
users get voice activated devices into
their home and it's
actually not clear to me.
If you want to turn on a desk lamp is
actually not clear to me that you want to
turn to a smart speaker and say,
Hey smart speaker,
please turn on that lab over there.
It may be a fuse one,
natural it just talk directly to a desk
lamp and tell it to turn on a term. Um,
and so, uh, also for wellness
where if someone were friends,
now we evaluated this,
we actually thought that this could be
a reasonable business to build embedded
devices to sell to lamp makers or other
device makers so that they can sell
their own voice activated devices without
needing this complicated wifi setup
process. Um, and so to do this,
you would need to build a learning
algorithm and have it run in an embedded
device. They just impose an audio
clip and I'll quiz, you know,
whenever it detects the,
the wake word and instead of a wake
where being activated the week where it
would be a lamp turn on or turn off,
you need to wake words or trigger words
one to turn it on, when to turn it off.
Right. Oh. And, and, and, and I
think just the other thing that, um,
I think would make this work,
uh, is, um, uh, uh, to, uh,
to give these devices names.
So if you have five lamps or two lambs,
you you need an way to index into these
different desk lamps. So, um, let's see,
you decide for your project, you
know, to have a little switch here.
So this lab could be called
John or Mary or Bob or hours,
like a four way switch.
So that's depending on where you said
this before we switch, you can see,
you know,
John very term on or is it if you
decide to call this lamb John,
like it was a goodness,
some of the names so you don't have
every land by the same name. Okay. Um,
so what I'm going to do is use as a,
a motivating example,
um, this as a possible project.
Oh. And I'm not working on this.
If any of you want to build a start up
doing this, go for it. I, I, this is not,
I felt my teams and I had better ideas
that we wanted to do other things in this,
but I should don't see
anything wrong with this.
I think this actually could be a
reasonable thing to come see us for help.
And I'm not doing it. So you are very
welcome to if you want. Okay. Um,
so now the question I
want to post you is a,
when you're brainstorming project ideas,
you know, like this idea, some other idea,
um, what are the things you would
want to watch out for? What,
what are the properties that you would
want to be true in order for you to few
good proposing this as a,
as a CSU 30 project, right?
So why should take a minute and write
this down? I think, uh, uh, uh, yeah.
What if you're asking a friend,
if a friend is asking you,
what are the things I should look at
to see if something has a big project,
what would you, what is your
recommended them? So feel free,
just write down a few keywords and then
we'll see what people say. And then,
and then I'll tell you what I tend to
look out for when I'm selecting projects
and they have lists of a five points.
Okay.
To take late, I don't know,
like two minutes to, oh,
sorry,
this is not activate it.
MMM.
I do not ever, the answer is
up and to answer this. Okay.
Let me test the Internet says
just checking it on. Yup. I am connected
to the Internet. Uh, it, any ideas?
Oh, I see. Okay. All
right. Let me try that.
Okay.
Thank you.
Oh yes,
thank you.
Thanks.
So can you take like two minutes to enter?
I think,
I think I can think of this and
let you enter multiple answers.
Let me stick tunes.
All right,
another one minute.
Okay.
Yeah.
Hi,
Miss 30 seconds.
Okay.
Yeah.
Sweet to one.
Well,
maybe in hindsight that
wasn't the best visualization.
Can people see this?
MMM,
well the line, trying to see if,
all right, so, uh, data novels,
he lost the data.
Some of these really small,
he wouldn't doable number of examples.
Do you have one, two months? No.
Office salvo. You industry a fields
a clear objective. Practical.
Useful.
Yeah.
Huh. Oh, can we finish in time? Uh,
host real life problem. Useful. Hasn't
been done computationally tractable.
Yeah. Generalization.
I see. Cool. Great. Um,
let me make some comments on fees. I
think I, this is, this is pretty good.
I had a list of five bullet points
that maybe I just share with you my,
this a five. Ah, um, which is I think
just some things I encourage you to
pay attention to. Um, you know, this,
this may or may not be the best criteria
but interests, interests, just, oh no,
it doesn't.
Hopefully you can work on something
that you're actually interested in. Um,
and then I think, uh, uh,
data availability,
which many of you cited is a good
criteria or one of the ways that, um,
Stanford cost projects sometimes do not
go well is if students spend a month to
try to collect data and after a monk
have not yet found the Datatel and then,
and then, you know, and then this and
then there's a lot of waste of time. Um,
one thing that I would encourage you
to consider as well is a domain knowledge.
Um,
and I think that if you are a biologist
and have unique knowledge into some
aspect of biology to which you
want to apply machine learning,
that will actually let you use
very interesting project, right?
That is actually difficult
for others to do. Um,
and I think more generally as, as advice
for navigating your careers. Right?
So you a shame because AI, machine
learning, deep learning, there's so much,
there's so many people wanting to jump
into machine learning and deep learning.
Um,
actually give an example.
So I sometimes talk to doctors
near Radiology students, uh,
including Stanford and other universities
realize you students that want to
learn about machine learning, right?
Because they hear about, you know,
deep learning, maybe someday
affecting radiologists as jobs.
And so they wanted to be politic learning.
And so my career advice to them is usually
to not forget everything they learned
as a doctor and try to,
you know,
do machine learning one on one from
scratch and just forget everything they
learned as a doctor and just become
a CS major. I think that that,
that path can work, but I
think we're radiologists
could do the most unique work,
uh,
that,
that allows them to make the most union
contribution is that they use their
domain knowledge of healthcare,
radiology and do something in machine
learning applied to radiology rate. Uh,
and so, all right. How, how, how many,
how many millennials
are there in this class?
What does that mean? Me, me, me, me thing.
All right.
This is really wrong.
I think it's because of the word cloud.
So very council where it frequency,
right? The money thing. I don't know.
I have very mixed feelings about that.
All
right. Um, but then as you for,
I actually know that some of you are
taking your deep learning because you work
in a different discipline and you
want to do something in this hot, new,
exciting thing of machine learning and
they think whatever this summit is you're
in. If your domain knowledge about
some of the area, you know, education,
civil engineering, biology, law, um,
taking deep learning allows
you to do very unique work,
applying machine learning
to your domain. Right? Oh,
let's see. Um, I think that, uh, uh,
um,
I think what I call the utility,
but several of you mentioned as well,
something that has a positive impact that
I should helps other people, uh, uh, uh,
I don't have money.
It could be an aspect of utility,
but maybe not the most inspiring
one. Uh, and then I think, um,
I think one of the biggest challenges
we faced in the industry today is,
so frankly there's actually a
good judgment on feasibility. Um,
so today I still see too many leaders are
sometimes CEOs of large companies that
stand on stage and announced
to the whole world, you know,
we're going to do this machine learning
project to do this by this deadline.
And then 20 minutes later I talked to
their engineers and the engineers say,
nope, no way not happening. Where
the CEO just farming this age,
Ho Ng modelization, there's not
doing it. And those is impossible.
So I think one of the biggest challenges
is actually feasibility, um, in, in fact,
I actually know that a, you know, that's a
chatter of rt, about, uh, the, the um, uh,
ta office hours. And I know that,
uh, uh, have been a lot of, you know,
long of you have been thinking
about applying a end to
end deep learning. Right.
You know, can you input any acts and
output any why and, and do the Acura the,
and sometimes it's possible
and sometimes it's not.
And it still takes a relatively deep
judgment about what new nether us can and
cannot do with a certain amount of data
that you may or may not be or April to
acquire in order to do some of
these things. Right. Um, so,
so I think throughout this quarter you've
gained much deeper judgment as well on
what is feasible. I guess
it was pretty interesting.
I once, no, uh, I,
I knew a CEO of a very large
company that once told his team,
um, uh, he actually gave us seem
decent structure. It's, he said,
I wish the assume that AI can do
anything. Uh, and, and, and it, it,
I think that had an interesting
effect, I guess. Uh, uh, uh,
yeah. Cool. All right.
So I think step one was selected project.
I hope there's this thing projects chose.
Keep some of those things in mind. Um,
step two is get data.
Um, and so, uh, what I want you to do,
and I'm going to pose a second question
and then have some to discuss this.
Let's say that you're actually
working on this, you know, smarts,
a voice activated embedded device thing,
right?
So let's say that you and your
friends want to build a startup.
So train the deep burning our
river to detect you there.
Phrases like John turned
on will marry you,
turnoff or Bob turned off or whatever
to sell to a device makers so that they
can a low voice embedded voice detection
chip that doesn't require a complicated
wifi set up process, right? So
let's see when, uh, let's see,
I actually want to do this.
So you need to collect some data in
order to site training or learning our
revenue. So, um, the second
question that I pose to you is, uh,
uh, uh, to, uh, question in two parts,
but I'll have you answer it all at the
same time, which is I'm in how many,
how many days?
Let's say you actually propose this
for your CSU 30 project this Sunday,
and then you start work on
it, you know, like on Monday,
are you going to start work on it
today before the proposal, but, uh,
how many days would you
spend collecting data? Uh,
and how would you collected data?
Okay. And I think, um, I actually,
how many of you have participated
in engineering scrum?
If you know what that means. Oh, okay. A
few of you. Those who have an industry.
Okay. All right. So
engineering estimation,
when you estimate how
long a project takes,
one of the common practices is use a
Fibonacci sequence to estimate how long a
project will take. Right? And so
people now she sequence one, one, two,
three, five, eight,
13 and so on.
And there's roughly powers of two,
but doesn't grow as fast as pilots too.
And FIBONACCI numbers are cool. Right? So,
uh, so, so whether one should they do
actually the me just finish over the
configuration.
Right.
Okay.
When I would,
um, speech bubbles.
Okay. Yeah, that's good.
All right. So what I'd like you
to do is in the text answer,
I really write two things.
One is write a number.
How many days do you think you spend
on collecting data union teammates if
you're actually doing this
project? Uh, and then how,
how would you go about
collecting the data?
Okay. So why don't you take
like another two minutes
to write in an answer.
Oh, I'm sorry. Let me say reload now.
Still not activated
Sarah down.
I'm trying to hit what we're just saying.
That is not helpful.
Okay. All right, Dennis.
Definitely not helpful.
Um hmm.
All right,
let's do this.
Write down your answer on a piece of paper
first and take two. And this is, yeah,
so the two questions off or how many days,
um,
pick a number for the people
Nachi sequence and uh,
or are you going to use
that all time? Oh, okay.
Let's swap out my computer for
rts. Oh, actually, yeah. Oh,
it hotties computers working.
Yeah, sure. Go ahead.
Oh yeah, I can just present. Let's plug
in your laptop. Just use your laptop.
Sure. Yeah, yeah.
Doesn't it say, I wonder if it's a death
where problem a web browser problem.
MMM.
I started that using a Firefox recently
in addition to chrome and Safari and
Dallas fire falls. I tried
with other web browsers. Liter.
Great. All right, cool. Thanks. Awesome.
All right. Maybe we have maybe people
that take another minute from now.
Just extend the time a bit.
All right.
10 seconds.
Yeah. All right, cool.
Let's see answers. Okay. All
right.
Well,
does, uh, does uh, does a lot of
variance in the answer is right.
MMM.
I know. Download from online depends on
what data you want. It turns out well.
So if you're trying to find data or
phrases like John turned on that that data
doesn't exist online.
Uh,
it turns out that you're trying to
find audio clips of the wet activate.
There are some websites with a
single worst pronouns, but those,
but I'm not a lot of audio clips actually.
You said they tried to word or the wake
word is the word activate a derail.
Some websites we can download like maybe
10 audio clips of a few people saying
activate,
but it's quite hard to find hundreds of
examples of different people saying that
we're activate.
MMM.
Five days,
it falls from the sky.
All right. So let me suggest, um,
uh,
let me suggest that you guys discuss
with each other in small groups, uh, what
you think would be the best strategy.
How many days would you find collecting
the data and how was your cycling?
Because anytime you try to convince
people next to you on that, um, and,
and before I asked you to
start discussing, I want to
leave you with one thought,
which is, um, how long do you think
it'll take you to train your first model?
Right? And so it will take you a day
to train your first Waldo or two days.
Uh, do you want to spend x time
collecting data and then spend,
let's say, you know, oh no,
it's a seventh deep learning thing and
train them all though it might take a
couple of days, right? Especially if
you download open source packages. So,
so if the amount of time needed to
collect data as x followed by two days to
train your first model, what do you
think? Extra beat the amount of time.
Why don't you guys spend like two minutes
to discuss with each other and see if
you can cut their, their, their answers
are, there's a very large areas, right?
Why don't you guys to
discuss if you actually,
if the people sitting next to
you or your project partners,
why should discuss with them how many
days do you think you should spank
collecting data and how
you collected data? Okay,
let's take two minutes to discuss an yeah.
Okay.
Yes.
All
right guys.
So,
all right guys. Hey guys. So
all right,
mother of exciting discussion. Um, uh,
so actually how many of you helped me up?
The groove swells up on the,
on the low end. How many of you, you know,
convince each other that maybe it
should be like three days or less?
Just a few of you. How come some assault
someone, someone to say, why, why is it,
why wife?
Because you're welcome to just to
see if that algorithm works first.
So you need some data to
just test to see a job were,
was even reaching sort of some sort of
good bench mark before you then go and
collect a massive dataset.
Cool.
Yeah,
I guess a little bit of the data to test
how the average horse before you even
go into like a massive
data set. Okay, cool. Yeah.
And did anyone has had a high end,
like a 13 days or more?
Very few. How come? Anyone edgy. Anyone,
anyone with insights you want to share
with the whole cloth as you, what,
what were you all
discussing? So excited. Yeah.
Okay. So, um,
depending on your domain
knowledge, um, data collection,
you can't take a long time,
especially with this problem,
like based on the one I get to the
system last year thinking like,
could we use like movie clips and
like sometimes it was too late,
generates on August minutes as
far as he was since you won.
And that would take like a thing
to like mine data from movies.
Good.
Yeah.
Right. Yeah. And so the
complicated systems and look
at it, a subtitle, videos,
right? Uh, like a youtube videos
have captions or something.
And if there's a the right creative
Commons day to day, I think it use. Yeah.
So let me,
let me tell you my bias.
[inaudible] I just tell you what I would
do if I was working on this project. Uh,
what, well, one caveat,
if I haven't done so much work in speech
recognition previously fragments was my
first project.
Um,
I would probably spend one to two days
collecting days Hara kind of on the short
end. Right? And I think that's,
um, you know, one of the, and, and,
and one of the reasons is that machine
learning kind of that circle I drew up
there is actually a very
iterative process where, um,
until you try it,
you,
you almost never know what's actually
going to be hard about the problem. Right?
And so, um, so if I was seeing this
project just so you all to see what,
what I would do, they like
it. I've actually thought
about this project a bunch,
right? Including, you know,
trying to validate market
acceptance and so on. But um,
which is that, um, I would
get a cheap microphone,
a user or use a built in
that top microphone or buy
a microphone off, you know,
buy a microphone off Amazon
or something and go around,
say go around Stanford campus and go to
your friends and have them just say, Hey,
do you mind saying to this microphone
there word activate or John Turner or
whatever, and collected a
bunch of data that way. Um,
and then, uh, uh, and
with one or two days,
um, you should be able to collect
at least hundreds of examples. Uh,
and that might be enough of a Dataset
to start training a rudimentary learning
algorithm to get going.
Because if you have not yet
worked on this problem before,
it turns out to be very difficult to
know what's going to be hard about the
problem. So is what's going to be hard,
um, highly accent of speakers, right? Uh,
always what's going to be hard background
noise or it's what's going to be hard,
you know, confusing turned
on. We've turned off, he's
year. John turned. And then,
uh,
but when you build a new machine,
learning any system is very difficult to
know what's hard and what's easy about
the problem or it was what's going to be
difficult that a far few, which is um,
the technical term for if the
microphone is very far away. Right?
So it turns out that if we turn on the
microphone on my laptop now, for example,
um, the, the laptop, which is what,
like three meters away from me, uh,
we'll be hearing voice directly from my
mouth as well as voice bouncing off the
walls. So there's lot of
reverberation in this room.
And so that makes me
free condition harder.
Humie are so good at processing our
reverberant sounds reverberations that you
almost don't notice it,
but it actually,
the learning room we'll have sometimes
has problems with reverberations,
echoes bouncing off the
hard walls of this room. Um,
and so depending on what you're
learning, Arbonne has trouble with. Um,
you will then want to go back to collect
very different types of data or explore
very different types of algorithms.
What was the problem that
sometimes the speaker,
that's just the volume is just
too soft in which case, you know,
maybe we need to do something else and
normalize all of your volumes of buying
more sensitive microphone or something.
So it turns out they weren't building
most machine learning applications unless
you've experienced working on it.
And so I've actually worked on this
problem before so I have a sense of what's
hot and it was easy, but they work on
the new project for the first time.
It's very difficult to know.
It was hard, it was easy.
And so my advice to most teams is rather
than spending say 20 days to collect
data and then two days to collect model
to train the model and is often by
training a model and then seeing
whether the examples it gets wrong.
When did the average fail that that
that's you feedback to either collect more
data or redesigned the model,
right?
Or try something else.
Um,
and if you can string the data collection
period down to be more comparable to
how long have you ended up
taking to train your model,
then you can start iterating
much more rapidly on,
on actually improving your
model. Right. Oh, and um,
so maybe one roof I'm actually tend to
recommend for most cost projects is oh no.
If, if maybe if he needs to spend a
week up to a week to collect data, yeah,
maybe that's okay. But it didn't
get going even will quickly. Uh,
I would even maybe more
strongly recommend that. Um,
and they've been so few examples in my
life where the first time I trained the
learning algorithm room, it works. Right?
It's like pretty much never happens.
It happened once about a year
ago and I was so surprised.
I still remember that one
time. Ah, and so what, so,
so, uh, machine learning development
is often a very iterative process.
And by quickly can I have days that
and often data sets a collected through
sweat and hardware,
right?
And so I wouldn't literally Yo and as w
I bet she thought long world speech and
it going quickly, I would
probably just um, uh,
have myself or my team members run
around and find people and asked them to
speak into a microphone and record
all your clips that way. Um,
and then only when you validate that you
need a bigger dataset. What'd you go to?
More complicated things. I set up an
Amazon Mechanical Turk thing, right?
To Krauss was, which I've
also done Ashley, right?
Also had very large DSF collect
off Amazon Mechanical Turk,
but only in a later stage the project
you understand what you really need.
All right. Um, so as you,
as you start working on your class
projects, maybe, maybe keep that,
keep that in their minds now. Um,
oh,
so one other tip that uh,
machine learning researchers on average,
we tend to be terrible at this.
Um,
but like if this advice anyway is when
you're going through this process,
get some data or design a model,
a literature search would be very helpful.
You also see what others see what our
rooms others are using. For this problem.
It turns out that literature
actually quite immature.
There isn't a convergence of,
uh,
like a well standard said
that standed out for him.
As for trigger words detection,
then lift your shirt.
Right now I should be boss still
making up algorithms. So if you,
if you do the survey,
you find that to be case,
but he didn't train the initial model.
Um,
and in most machine learning applications
who go through this process multiple
times.
So one tip that I would recommend
you do is keep clear notes.
Okay.
Um,
on the experiments you've run,
right?
Because
so often be, uh, as he trade
them all though, you see, oh,
this model where it's a great on the
American accent of speakers but not on
British accent to speakers,
right. I was born in the UK,
so I'm just gonna use British
accents, right? Example, if a,
for a different part of the world,
you have to think of different global
access descends down from the UK.
I'm just gonna pick on
British accents, I guess. Um,
keep clearing those on
the experiments run.
Because what happens in every machine
learning project is after a while you have
trades 30 models and then you and
your team members a good, oh yeah,
we tried that idea two weeks ago,
did it work?
And if you have clear notes from when
you actually did that work two weeks ago,
then you can refer back route. Didn't
have to be run experiments. Oh,
the other thing that some groups do is uh,
have a spreadsheet that keeps track
of what's the learning rate you use,
what's the number of head and unions
was this was this was this or, or, or,
or cheaper than a text documents.
So that,
which will make it easier to refer back
to it, to know something you try earlier.
Um,
this is one piece of comedy given advice.
And this is one of those things that
every machine learning person knows we
should do this, but on average we're
very bad at doing this. But that,
that you could, I don't know. Uh, but at
the Times I managed to keep good notes.
It actually saved them all the time.
Right. To try. Remember what exact view.
Tried two weeks ago. Okay. So, um,
a lot of this class will be on
this process of how they get data,
develop the chain Dev, test, the
design, the model to train the model,
eventually test them all the innovate.
So a lot of this causes on this,
so when they jump ahead to when you have
a good enough model and you wanted to
deploy it. Okay. So step
six, I guess since deployment
now, um, uh, uh,
this is uh, oh, um,
one of the reasons I want to step through
this example going through a concrete
example is I find that when
you're learning about machine
learning for the first
time is often seeing, you know, what,
what my team sends it called war stories,
kind of stories of projects that,
that,
that others have built before that often
provides the best learning experience.
So I think like,
I have built speech recognition systems,
it tells me like a year or two years and
so we need to do it. So I'm trying to,
so rather than, you know, having you spend
two years of your life building speech,
the sims if can summarize a war story,
right?
To tell you what the process is like.
I'm hoping that these concrete examples
of what building these systems,
our life in large corporations that
that can help you a salary of learnings
without needing to get two
years of on the job experience.
You can just hear the
salient points. Okay. Now,
if you're deploying a system like this,
one of the things,
and this is actually true,
there's actually a real phenomenon for
deploys speech systems is you have the
audio clip, you have a neuro
network, and then, you know,
this will all put zero one. And, um,
the neural networks that work well,
we'll tend to be relatively large,
relatively large model, the Laotian or
hidden Eunice, relatively high complexity.
And, um, if you have some of the
smart speakers in your home, um,
you recognize that a lot of them are
h devices as opposed to a purely cloud
computation, right? So we all
know what the cloud is. Um, uh,
and what an edge devices,
edge devices,
the smart speaker that's in your home
or the cell phone and your wallet.
So a edge devices are, you know, the
things that are close to the data,
I suppose in the cloud, which is a giant
surface we have in our data centers,
right? So, um, because of
network latency, uh, uh,
and uh, uh, and, and,
and because of privacy,
a lot of these computations are done
on edge devices like a smart speaker in
your home or, uh, like a,
I guess, Hey Siri or, okay,
Google can wake up your cell phone,
right?
And so edge devices have much lower
computational budgets and much lower power
budgets are limited battery life,
much less powerful processes than
we have in our cloud data centers.
And so it turns all that salt,
salt serving up a very large neural
network is, it's quite difficult.
It's very difficult for,
you know, a low power,
inexpensive microprocessor sitting in a
smart speaker in your living room to run
a very large neural network with a
lot of hidden units and with all the
parameters.
And so what is often done
is to actually
do this,
which is, um, to input an audio clip
and then have a much simpler algorithm,
uh,
figure out if you know anyone who has
even talking, right? Because, uh, oh,
so the smart speaker in my living room,
he was silence most of the day, right?
Because usually just no one at home,
right? There's no, no, no voice.
And then only if it hears,
you know,
someone's talking then feed it to the big
neural network that you've trained and
GRANDPA use a larger part budget. Um, uh,
in order to classify zero one. Okay. Um,
just component goes by many
different names, uh, um, in,
in reasonably standard terminology,
but not totally standard
terminology in the literature.
I'm going to call this VA, um,
for voice activity detection,
right?
Oh, it turns out that voice
activity, it's actually,
there's a standard component is in, in
many different speech recognition systems.
If you are using a cell phone,
for example,
a VAT is a component that tries
to figure that hands even talking.
Because if it thinks no one is talking,
then there's no need to encode the audio
and tried to transmit the audio right
onto cause,
you know?
Um, and so, uh,
so the next question I want to ask you,
and I thought this is
timely because, um, uh, uh,
wow
is, um, a couple of options, right?
Option one is to build a non
machine learning VAT system,
voice activity detection system,
which is just, you know, see,
okay,
if the volume of the audio,
your spa speakers recording
has greater than epsilon.
So the side is just to get it.
And option two is a train
a small neuronetwork,
um, uh, to recommend
on, on, on human speech.
Right.
Um, and so, uh,
my next question to you is if
you're working on this project,
which you pick option one or what'd you
pick options? Who? Great. Uh, as you,
as you, as you move to what, oh,
sorry. And I think, um, a small,
newer network,
a small network or in some cases I've
seen people use this small support vector
machine as well. For those.
He didn't know what that is.
A small wall that it can be wrong
with a low computational budget.
This is a much simpler problem to
detect that someone is talking then to
recognize the word they said.
So you could actually do this.
You don't know what reasonable
accuracy was. Small, newer network.
But if you actually work on
this project, uh, for CSU 30,
which would you try for us? So Michelle,
can we go onto the next question? Yes.
Okay, cool. Figure out how
to do that. Sure. Yeah.
We can let them start answering I guess.
And then why you figured
out the projection.
Cool.
I'm just keep unlocking it periodically.
Are People able to vote?
No. The no votes yet.
Well,
I see.
I guess you write so much code,
you have a shortcut to go to your
coding environment or your laptop
on the whole.
Great.
All right, cool. Great. Thank you.
Hello. All right. Yvonne,
him quickly and now
they're like 20 seconds,
if that's enough time to give you answers.
Oh,
cool.
All right, cool. Um,
okay,
that's fascinating. There's a lot
of disagreement in this Hos, um, uh,
people want to say why,
why would you choose option one?
Why would you choose often to, and, and I,
I have a very strong point of view
on what I would do. Right. Uh, but,
but I'm curious why, uh,
why option one and why two
go ahead.
Easy to debug issues
either.
I was option one officer,
actually simple
options. Who's not the harder
dog in your house and carts and pros,
they're activated.
You can probably out already like simplify
the problem that knowing if a noise,
I mean activates the machine.
But that's why I picked up
there may be people have like
three
options,
noisy place
and
I think it will pick up the background
noise. You have a friend
who's a train station,
right? So option one, we'll
pick up a lot. The pain
has to be running constantly,
very cheap.
So it seems like option
one is better because
no power,
no country.
So let me show you some
of the pros and cons. Uh,
so I think there are pros
and cons of option one.
Option two is why
so many volts,
but both options I proceed with
choose option one. Um, but,
but let me just, let's just discuss the
pros and cons. Right? I think that um, uh,
option one first is just a
few lines of code is yes,
maybe option two isn't that complicated,
but option one is even simpler.
And I think that, um, uh,
maybe I would say if I hadn't
worked on this problem before,
I would choose option one.
Uh,
but since I have experienced as feet
recognition eventually I know you need
option too. But that's because I, because
I've worked on this problem before,
but there's your first time working
on the speech application problem.
I would encourage you on
average to try to really simple,
quick and dirty solutions and
go ahead. And, um, so let's see,
how long would it take to implement this?
Right?
I would say like 10 minutes or
five minutes. I Dunno. Right?
Hollywood thinking to implement that.
Oh hell for all of us one
day or I don't really know.
Actually right now, let me just write one
day and then I'm not quite sure. Great.
But if I'm often went
to BMC in 10 minutes,
then I will encourage you to do that and
go ahead and put the smart speaker in
your home or in your
potential users homes.
And only when you find out that the dog
barking is a problem or the train on
their airways, seizure,
no, whatever is a problem,
then go back and invest more in the
fixing it. Right. And in fact, um,
it's true that maybe it's annoying if the
dog barking and keeps on waking up the
system. But maybe that's okay
because if the launch neural network,
then screens are all the dog barking then
the overall performance systems as you
just fine and, uh, and,
and you now have a much simpler
system. Right? But, uh, but,
but it turns out that the reason you might
need to go to option to eventually is
because they're awesome homes in
noisy environments. Uh, you know,
this constant background noise.
And so that will keep the large neural
nets were running a little bit too
frequently. So, so if you have a
large engineering budget, you know,
so some of the smart speaker teams are
like hundreds of engineers working on it
so they have hundreds of
injuries and work on it. Totally.
Option two will perform better.
But if you're strapped startup team is
scrappy startup team lift fee of you
working on a class project, you
know, the evidence that you need,
that level of complexity is not that high.
And I would really do that first and use
that to gather evidence that you really
should make the investment to build a
more complex system before actually making
the investments of days off.
And eventually,
I think this is one day to pull
your first photo. All right.
And then eventually you'll be,
I'll be more complicated. Um,
it turns out that, um, did other reason,
um, the other huge advantage of
the simple method is the following.
Um,
and this is one of the faculty.
This is one of the,
there's actually one of the big problems
and big weaknesses of machine learning
algorithms and deep learning algorithms,
which is what happens is, uh, um,
when you build a system and you should
ship a product, the data will change,
right? And so, um, I'm going to simplify
the example a little bit, but you know,
I know Stanford is very cosmopolitan.
There's Powells is very hospital. See,
we collect data in this region. You get
access from people all over the world,
right? Because, because that's
Stanford, that's Palo Alto. But,
but just to simplify these apple
orbit, um, let's say that you train
on a u s accents, right? Uh,
but you know, for some reason, uh,
uh, when you're ship a product,
maybe it sells really well in
the UK and you start getting data
okay.
With a UK or with British accents.
All right,
so one of the biggest problems you
face in practical deployment of machine
learning systems is that the day to train
on is not going to be the day you need
to perform well on. Um, and,
and I'm gonna share with you some
practical ideas for how to solve this,
but this is one of those
practical realities and
practical weaknesses is machine
learning that is actually not talked
about much in academia. Uh, uh,
because it turns out that the data says
we have in academia are not set up well
for researchers to study and
published papers on this.
I think we could sell a new machine there,
any benchmarks in the future,
but this is one of those problems as
it's actually kind of underappreciated in
academic literature.
But that is a problem facing many,
many practical deployments are
machine learning algorithms. Um,
and uh,
and so more general,
the problem is one of data
changing, right? And, uh,
you might have new houses of users
with new accidents or you
might train a lot on, uh,
the maybe get data from even
Stanford users and maybe Stanford.
It's not too noisy.
All staff are there certain types of
cars in the states where you ship it to
another city, another country.
There's much more noisy, uh, you know,
different background noise.
Okay.
Right?
Or you start manufacturing the smart
speaker and to lower the costs of the
speaker,
they swap it out.
They swap out the high end microphones
that you use from your laptop to collect
the data for lower and microphone.
It's a very common thing done in, yeah,
well done in manufacturing, right?
If you could use a cheaper microphone,
why not? Right. And often to a human eras,
the sound sounds just fine
on the cheaper microphone.
But if you change your learning algorithm
using your, you know, I guess, yeah,
well I use a Mac,
but the Mac is a pretty decent microphone.
So if you train the data using all
collateral Mac and then eventually as a
different microphone,
it may not generalize well.
So one of the challenges of,
um,
machine learning is that you often develop
a system on one dataset and then when
you ship a proud out, something about
the world changes, uh, and, and,
and your system needs to perform on a
very different type of data than what
you've had training. Um, and so,
um,
and so what will happened is
after you deployed a model,
uh, the world may change and you're
often end up going back to get more data.
We designed the model, right?
And, and I guess, sorry, and
this is, this is, uh, uh,
the maintenance of the
machine learning model. Um,
I want to give some of those
apples a web search, right?
This happens all the time and multiple
of us search engines, which is, uh,
you train a neural network or you train
the system to give relevant web search
results, but then something about the
world changes. You are, for example,
there's a major political,
then some new person is elected president
of some foreign country or does a
major scandal or just the Internet
changes, right? Or there's a,
actually what happens in China is a new
word getting invented all the time in,
in China, the China. So is
that by of I Google and Baidu,
but the Chinese languages a more
fluid than the English language.
And so new worst he invented all the time.
And so the language changes.
And so whether it be a trade just isn't
working as well as it used to. Right.
Um, or, or maybe a different company,
southern shuts off, you know,
their entire website to your search
index because we don't want you, uh,
indexing their website.
And so internet changes and what have
you had done doesn't work anymore. Um,
or um, uh, self driving.
Uh,
it turns out that you build a self driving
car in California and then you tried
to deploy these vehicles
in Texas. Um, you know,
it turns out traffic lights in Texas look
very different than traffic lights in,
in, in California. So, um, although
I trained on California, Texas on,
so a newer network trained to recognize
a California traffic ones actually
doesn't work very well on
Texas traffic leads. Right? Oh,
I'm trying to remember
which way round than us.
But I think California and Texas has
a different distribution of horizontal
versus vertical traffic lights, for
example. It's actually a human's,
they'll notice if you
go, oh yeah, red, yellow,
green for the learning algorithm
doesn't actually generalize that well.
If you go to a different location
and go to a foreign country, again,
traffic lights, signage, the
lean markers or change, um,
or I guess, well one example I was
working on earlier this week, right? Uh,
manufacturing, right? Learning Ai,
working on inspection of
parts in factories. Um,
and so if you are doing visual inspection
in the factory and the factory starts
making a new component, you know, they
were making this model cell phone,
but cell phones turned over quickly.
And so, but in a few months later,
they're making a different type of cell
phone or something weird happens in
manufacturing process. So the lighting
changes as new type of defect.
So the world changes.
And um,
so I'm knocking again,
what I like to do is I'm actually
revisit the previous question in light of
this, uh, the world changes
phenomenon, right? Which is,
let's say you've collected a lot of data.
We an American accent of speakers. Um,
and then, you know, we shut the
product in the UK and then, um,
and then for some reason you find that
you've all these British accents speakers,
right? Trying to use your spot. Speaker.
So between these two algorithms
and our machine learning approach,
which is a set the threshold
versus train the neural network,
which system do you think will be more
robust for Vat? Boys activity detection.
Okay.
All right. I'm particularly
another, I'll know 40 seconds.
All
right.
Yeah. Interesting to people
when they comment, well,
more people voted for this one.
Let me explain why.
No,
go ahead.
If we want to detect
that and instead,
right.
So say for the VAT,
if you just measure the volume that it
doesn't really depend on on the accent,
so non ml might be more robust.
Anyone else?
All right.
So,
okay. Again, you show you, I thought,
so it turns out that if you
train a small neuronetwork, uh,
to um, uh, you know, American
accent, his speech, uh,
there's a bigger chance that your neural
network, because it's so clever, right?
They'll learn to recognize American
speech and have a harder time generalizing
to British accented speech.
Does that make sense?
And so one of the things that I've
seen a lot of teams are, whereas,
so, so one way the non GMO thing could
fail to generalize would be a British
speakers are systematically,
you know,
allow there are softer than the
American speakers. Right? So, you know,
I don't know, I don't have
Americans stereotypically allowed,
there are less loud than
British, but, but you know,
but the American and British speakers,
one country just as loud a
voice as a softer voices,
then maybe the threshold you set won't
generalize. Well, but that seems unlikely.
I don't see that being realistic thing.
But um,
but they have a training on your own
network, a lot of parameters then, uh,
is more likely that the neuro network,
we're pickup on some idiosyncrasy of
American accents to decide the 70s even
speaking. Um, and does,
maybe that's robust who generalizing
to a British accent it speech. Right.
And another way to think about the, or
imagine to take an even further example,
imagine that you're using Va d for a
totally different language than they then
English, right? Where um, take
a different language, you know,
Chinese or Hindi or Spanish or something
where the sounds of really different.
If you create a VAT system
to detect, you know, English,
it may not at all work for detecting
Spanish or Chinese or French or,
or some other language. Um, and so
if you think of British accents as a,
as somewhere on the spectrum,
not the foreign language by any means,
but just more different than I think the
[inaudible] system is more likely to be
robust. Right. And so one of
the lessons that too many that,
that a lot of machine learning teams
during the hard way it is, uh, um,
if you don't need to use a
learning algorithm or something,
if you can hand called the simple rule,
like if volume greater than
0.01 do this or that, uh,
those rules are,
can be more robust.
And the one of the reasons
we use only our rooms,
it's where we can't hang caught something,
right?
I don't know how the handcuffs something
to detect the cat or to the car on the
road or detective the person.
So use learning Alvin's with those.
But if there was actually a hand called
the rule that actually does pretty well,
you find that it is more robust to shifts
into data and what often generalized
better. Oh, and uh, if any
of you take, uh, uh, we,
we talk a bit about this a little bit in
cs two, three, nine a I think CSC here,
90 talks about this as well.
But this book,
the observation is backed up by very
rigorous learning theory and the learning
theory is basically that the
fewer parameters you have, uh,
if you still do well in your training set,
if you kind of model with
very few parameters that
does well and your training
set your generalized
better, right? So there's,
there's very rigorous machine learning
theory that basically says that.
And in the case of the non
machine learning approach,
there's maybe one parameter
which is what's the threshold
for epsilon and that's
worthwhile enough for your training set.
Then your odds of a generalizing even
when the data changes is much higher
right.
Now,
the last question,
um,
I want to post with
discussion today is, um, when,
when discussing deployments, uh, oh
and so one of the lessons deployments,
that's just the way the world works,
you know,
the machine learning system and deploy it,
the world will usually change and you
often end up collecting data and having an
elevator and maybe improve the model,
right?
And then they'll fix them off
a previous speakers happen. Um,
so we talked about edge deployments
as well as cloud deployments,
right? And so, um,
ignoring issues of user privacy and
latency, which is super important.
But for the purposes, the
question, let's, let's,
let's put aside issues of user
privacy and network latency. Um,
if you need to maintain them all though,
sorry. Maintenance means updating them.
Haldol, right? Even as
the world changes, um, oh,
sorry. I miss uh, miss tabby should be,
does he cow or h deployment make
maintenance easier if not earth. Right?
Why don't you, why don't you just enter
a one word answer and, and, and why,
right? And so managing that is this, when
the world changes, something changes.
So you need to update the
learning model to take advantage,
take care of this British accent. So
which type of deployment makes it easier?
Mystic Lake. Yeah. Another two
minutes. Send to your answers.
Yeah.
All right.
Another like 50 seconds.
All right, cool. See
what people are routes.
Wow. Cool, great. All right.
Almost everyone in the St Cloud,
most people are saying
cloud. All right, cool.
Great.
And then just to summarize,
I think they're actually two
reasons why most people send,
it's easier to push updates.
That's part of it.
I think the other positive is that
if all the data that is at the edge,
if all the data is processed yo and it
uses home and none of it comes to cloud,
then even if you have all these
unhappy British accents to users,
you may not give him the fine Dell. Right?
You're saying the company headquarters,
you have all these users and
this theory is these, you know,
seem to be not using your device maybe
cause they're unsatisfied with it.
But if the data isn't coming to your
servers in the cloud that you may not even
find out about it. Now there are
serious issues about user privacy, uh,
as we as security, right? So, so, so
please, if you have a brother product,
please be respectful of that.
Uh, and then take, take,
take care of that in very thoughtful
and respectful way of users. But, um,
uh, for us, um, so this
is the cloud, right?
If you have a lot of edge devices
and all the data is processed there,
you won't even know what your users
are doing and they're happy, unhappy,
you just don't know.
But if some of the data in the stream to
your servers of the cow and if the user
privacy with really easy
as good user consent,
tell people what you're doing with the
data. But if you take care of that in a,
in a, in a, in a, in
these moe and sound way,
if you're able to examine some of the
data that you can at least figure out that
gee, looks like analyzing the data.
There are these people, if this accident,
this background noise that um,
uh, is, uh, giving it back.
Other days be rinse and you can also
maybe have the data so you can gather the
data from the edge to feed
back to your model, right? So,
so that's you detect if
something's gone wrong. Um,
unless you have the data to retrain
the model to solve the British accent
problems are going to retrain the model
a lot British accent to speech. Um,
and if find it, he lets you push them
all back home, right? So of course,
and that's, you detect what's going
on too. It gives you data for training
and see, unless you're more easily
push the model back up, pushing,
pushing the new model to
production to deployments. Okay.
And does this also why, uh, even if your
compensation needs to run on the edge,
if you could in a way respectful of user
privacy in this transparent about how
you use data.
If you can get even a small sample
of data or have a few volunteer uses,
sent you some dates back to the cloud,
that will greatly increase your ability
to detect if something Kahn wrong as
well as maybe give you some
data to retrain the model. Uh,
so even if you can hold you too.
So the push updates, right. This,
this will just will help.
Creepy. Okay. Um, all right.
So finally the one last
comment, I think, uh, one, one,
one last challenge is a lot of
the machine learning systems,
you're not done at deployment.
There's a constant ongoing maintenance
process and I think one of the processes,
uh, you know, AI teams are
getting better at as well.
I set up Qa to make sure that we update
the model. You don't break something.
So then Qa and large company
is quality assurance process.
It's kind of testing this and I think
the way you test machine or the arb rooms
is different than the way you test,
which are,
there is no software because
the performance of machine
learning algorithms is
often measured the status call way, right?
So it doesn't work. And it doesn't work.
It either works or doesn't work.
Instead that works, you know,
95% of the time or something.
And so a lot of companies are
evolving the Qa processes,
they have this type of statistical
testing to make sure that you don't,
you changed them all, then you do a
push update. It's the works, you know,
95 or 99% of the time or
something rather than so, so,
so putting in place new Qa
test processes as well. Okay.
All right.
I hope that was helpful.
Stepping through what the full arc of a
machine learning project will look like,
uh, uh, will,
will they did this course or any course
suite as well as in a later lecture
there are present,
we'll keep talking about machine learning
strategy and how they make decisions.
So let's break for today.